cent jours de solitude
une invitation lancée par le frac qui a
demandé à plusieurs artistes de livrer
leur vision de la solitude du droit au
repli dans un monde saturé
pour l'agencé espagnole taxes cela donne
cet auditorium une sorte de robe baptisé
crinoline leurs idées c'est à dire quand
on est au centre on est dans l'espace du
collectif dans le véritable auditorium
mais si on veut profiter de ce qui se
dit un peu plus en solitaire on va
s'asseoir dans les creux de la robe
on peut écouter et voir ce qui se passe
sans être vu la solitude ça peut être
aussi celle de l'artiste face à des
oeuvres numériques générées par un
logiciel sans auteur finalement la
création se libère de son créateur c'est
le sens de ce dispositif d'hybridation
numérique qui génèrent des réactions
diverses
vu qu'on est sur un thème qui met en
avant que l'effective mans le numérique
ne saturent on va très très vite il faut
savoir qu'une image ici et créer en une
seconde quand on compare à notre temps
humain pour créer c'est totalement
effrayant et ça s'est ressenti justement
par les visiteurs
le conceptuel n'empêche pas la poésie
les visiteurs déambulent dans
l'exposition entre des formes et des
matériaux très divers et peu importe si
le sens des oeuvres n'est pas toujours
évident le but est de provoquer des
échanges
je me suis demandé un peu comment il
avait réussi à trouver des oeuvres en
lien entre l'architecturé la solitude et
je trouve enfin verizon trouvé plein de
choses différentes sont c est quand même
assez intéressant cette biennale est
conçu comme un hymne à la solitude pour
les commissaires pouvoir être seul voilà
la fir du siècle le grand reset perd sa
solitude
je ne dis pas perdre son isolement
isolement est un mal social sociétal etc
mais si tu perds ta solitude parce qu'il
faut être seul pour penser il faut être
seul pour être libre
faut être seul pour aimer c'est ça la
valeur de la solitude et la grande
menace actuellement dans le capitalisme
mondialisé
c'est nous faire perdre notre solitude
il ya plus possibilité d'être seul et le
rôle de l'architecte et d'apporter les
conditions de cette solitude de façonner
ce monde protecteur et émancipateur